the three a.m. is just a waiting time
you know you got a gotta get situated
there so uh so the the talk title did
built in syrup superheroes I was trying
to think about a I don't know like a
topic for this this conference and it
turns out this kind of marks like the 20
year anniversary of me using Python I've
been thinking about you know like how do
I use it over the years or like what
have I used it for what do I get out of
it and one of the I think the major use
of Python for me is as like a personal
productivity tool
oh so it's a little bit of a little bit
of background I actually was a little
weird this morning the keynote talk
there was this slide talking about the
scaling of these like particle codes on
supercomputers I don't know whether
anybody remembered that talk I got
started in Python as one of the data
points on that graph I actually was
working on molecular dynamics in a
physics group doing particle codes on
supercomputers back in sort of you know
1996 and one of the things about that
that work is that you know we were
dealing with big data at the time and we
were doing supercomputing code big data
in that in that era would have been like
16 gigabytes which is I find amazing cuz
like my phone has 64 gigabytes so it's
you know we're dealing with you know
these 16 gigabyte data files and a lot
of what we were doing is you know we've
run these things on the supercomputer
that would maybe only take you know like
10 hours or something like that and then
it would take weeks to analyze because
we're just doing all this stupid stuff
like transferring files around and
trying to convert file formats and like
get data in from one tool to another
tool and other other stuff and one of
the things that got me into Python was
it it's kind of a tool for dealing with
all of this really annoying crap you
know it's like the problem that we're
trying to solve but then there's like
all this other you know all these other
stuff like managing data so you know
that in the data science we're all you
hear this you know this this phrase you
know it's like 90% of your time is spent
like munging the data
like 10% is actually doing something
with it so that was very much the case
for uh for me and in thinking about like
using Python since then I was trying to
think like what is the real secret
weapon of the language so to speak and
honestly I think it's the built-in types
this might seem kind of like a basic
thing to be talking about but if I
actually honestly look at how I use by
the day to day and what I use that use
that use it for the most it's it's
basically manipulating things like
topples lists sets dictionaries various
things from the collections module and
and and and so forth and I think like
like knowing about that is really kind
of the key to becoming some kind of
python wizard like i mean if you really
want to get like your hands into the
nuts and bolts of the language and doing
stuff having like some can may end over
that is a like a really useful useful
skill now some of the some of the
reasons for this I thought it would kind
of like spell out some of the things
that I think about with the built-in
types of ones that they're everywhere
there's also a great deal of flexibility
there's a performance aspect and there's
a fun aspect so what I wanted to do is
actually talk about these for a second
here so I'm gonna I'm gonna iterate
through those and just talk about some
of the reasons here so the first thing
the first thing is that I've bought in
Python slightly okay so so the first
things just like the fact that the
built-in types or everywhere like if you
hate Python packaging the built-in types
are for you basically I mean those are
those are available like all versions of
Python all operating systems all
distributions you don't need to install
anything they're just always there you
can use them to do stuff so that's one
that's one facet of it just always
available there's a huge amount of
flexibility with the built-in types I
mean yeah you can make lists out of
anything you can make these very
complicated data structures list of
tuples and dictionaries and sets and
things and it's like you know it's it's
awesome it's like what if you if you
have
we can you kind of get your mind in that
space it's like you have this set of
tools and you can do all sorts of
amazing things with those the
performance side of it is maybe a little
bit weird but I feel like the built-in
types are fast for my time as a coder
basically it's uh you know things like
memory is super cheap like if I need a
lot of memory I can just spin up
something on Amazon and create as many
Python dictionaries as I can possibly
imagine on there now now maybe if I'm
trying to put some code into production
later on I'd want to think about it it'd
be a little bit smarter about things
using you know number or pandas or
something something like that but as as
far as just getting something off the
ground fast built-in types are great for
that let me just kind of mess it around
with stuff prototyping things it's it's
more like my time that I'm trying to
trying to optimize it's not optimized
there and then the the other thing is
just the I know there's like a certain
fun quality to it I mean I I sort of
feel like the built-in types aren't this
sense like little building blocks they
abstract away a lot of annoying details
like I don't have to think about memory
management right it's like I want to
think about that they don't completely
solve the problem usually that I'm
trying to trying to do I mean it's like
it's not like a it's not like a just
like a turnkey thing where it's like I
plug in my data and it just magically
solves the problem
um which which actually means you have
to think a little bit about what you're
doing and and and for me that's actually
what makes programming fun is to
actually still have to think about stuff
you know it's like oh how am I gonna
solve this problem but I think if I
didn't have that I would just give up
programming your nozzoli yeah there's
got to be like a fun fun quality to it
there's also a certain reward for
cleverness which is a little bit of a
dangerous things I'm thinking about the
rant about physics code that somebody
gave earlier and I got started coding
the physicists right and you know
there's like this so clever physics code
and like people start running out of the
running out of the room I did this
cleverness thing okay maybe that's not
what you want to do if you're writing
like production code for like a big team
or something like that but if you're
just coding like it's a personal
productivity
kind of thing you got to be rewarded by
you know clever tricks and and and and
so forth so so what I wanted to do in
that in the in the toy it's actually
made me just do do a few things kind of
kind of review the built-in types and
then to kind of a fun sort of data
hacking project if you will that will be
appropriate for after watch you'll see
why second here so so the just just just
a review of what's available essentially
the built-in types that you work with
you have tuples essentially what topple
is it's like a row out of a database
that's how I commonly use it so like if
I were to make like a record or
something or a row I would say you know
like I could have like a top bowl that
has different elements in it maybe like
a street address you know something like
that usually what you're talking about
with the topple is your it's like a row
out of a table a CSV file something like
that there is a maybe a close cousin of
tuples that named topple object that's
in the collections module if you've
never seen that before
one of the complaints about tuples is
that sometimes people will write code or
index in there via like a number and it
turns out if you do that too often your
co-workers will want to hit you I know
it's you know it's because because like
writing code that has all these hard
coding into season they're really kind
of awful so one of the things that you
can that you can do is pull in this like
named topple object and sort of declare
like a like a structure of some kind it
looks a little weird but you can you
know assuming that I can type this thing
here okay so maybe you make something
like that and then what you can do is
use that in place of like a normal tub
what that lets you do is you can use
dotted attribute so if you've never seen
that before it's definitely worth kind
of tucking away it's kind of a useful
trick so that's one of the one of the
data types is toppled another data type
is pythons list object okay so this is
essentially the built in version of an
array if you will I mean it's this list
of items
the main use of it is enforcing order to
be honest like if you ever need to rank
data or sort things or preserve order
put it in a list you'll you'll keep the
order one important thing about it again
you can put anything you wanted a list
so if you want to list the strings or
lists of numbers you put it in there you
do different different things with it
another useful data type is Python set
object this is very useful for a sort of
uniqueness and membership testing kinds
of things so one one critical thing
about like a like a list for instance
like if you got a list I don't know
let's let's let's put some names in
there if you had any kind of duplicate
you know this that just that it just
stores everything that you give it so if
you have more than one thing with the
same value list will capture that if you
make a set instead you're gonna drop all
the duplicates out so you get just the
unique items so it's a very pretty
common thing with sets to do things like
duplicate elimination membership testing
and so forth pythons dictionary object
very useful for making like indices and
mapping between things so if you need to
do things like look-up tables or or
anything like that dictionary is
extremely useful useful for that
essentially what you're doing with a
dictionary is is mapping keys to values
maybe you're maybe you have a list of
things like stock names versus stock
prices or something what what a
dictionary will do is do quick lookups
on that like you can say give me the
price of Acme or something and then you
can add and delete things from from
dictionary some other data types that
come into play and this is kind of a
quick review there are some things in
the collections module like counter
objects are pretty interesting and
default dictionary objects are pretty
interesting so little review on that
essentially what a counter is is it's a
dictionary that's meant for tabulation
just to see some examples on that if I
were to say C is a counter of X Y Z Z Y
for instance what that's going to do is
build a dictionary that counts up the
letters that you just gave it
okay so it's like you know two Z Y 2 X 1
you can essentially use this to sort of
tabulate more information later ah so
it's like a it's like a dictionary where
you can you know add counts and just
sort of keep keep track of those we're
gonna do some examples of that a little
a little bit later a default dictionary
this is sort of a kind of an interesting
object to work with if you haven't seen
it before but what it what I tend to use
it for a lot is making dictionaries that
express a one-to-many relationship where
you have to group like doing grouping of
data or some kind of you know one one to
many kind of thing the way that this
works is you make a default dict
and then you specify what the initial
contents are going to be like a list or
a set or something and then what this
lets you do is you can combine
dictionary insertions with things like
list append do a few few examples there
what it's doing is its building up a
dictionary where you can see like on
that spam it's got two values there one
was 42 one was 10 could be a very useful
way of kind of clustering data grouping
data and and so forth so all of all
these things these are if these are kind
of two built-in types that I'm talking
about and again these are I would say
these are like the bulk of a lot of
day-to-day coding for me you know it's
like you know I may be from PyCon I get
a reputation for people think ah Dave's
just sitting it is what do you call evil
layer or something
well diabolical and just sitting in the
layer just doing like medic glasses or
something it's like I'm really sorry to
- your view of me but like like by 90
percent of my day is spent doing things
like database queries with like lists
and stopping it's not that it's not like
metaclasses yeah they're my modern
interpreter yeah so so alright so so
that's that's what we're starting with
now there are some some other kind of
basic powers that kind of enter the
picture here you don't don't ask
interfer so a lot of things that go on
with the for-loop this is a very common
way of iterating over data is to do a
for loop on it there are some things
like a numerate and zip that you might
see there are some reduction functions
like some min and Max any/all and so
forth actually actually on the subject
of these reductions I find it really
interesting that Python has never had
stats functions as part of the standard
library until really recently I think
like I don't think there was a function
in the whole standard library to do a
mean or an average until Python 3 points
for maybe 3 3 but it was like 3.4 I find
that kind of amazing because Python has
been used for science for like 20 years
so wait it's like a total mystery like
why I would be missing but there is a
statistics module that has some other
other other things in there as well
there are some more advanced powers that
we'll get into I would say the super
powers of the of the built-in types or
when you get into things like list
comprehensions set comprehensions and
dictionary comprehensions a very common
thing that you might have is you might
have a list and then you need to do some
kind of transformation on it like maybe
I want to take all those numbers and
square it I could do something you know
like this for I could do like a you know
like a manual for Lu like that I mean
that that's that's one way to treat like
you take a list and you transform it but
that is just way too much typing I would
much rather just do a shortcut this is a
sample the list comprehension you just
say ok why not want to say you know x
times X for X and noms that will make a
list that carries out that calculation
gives you the gives you the result so
there are some nice shortcuts related to
that we're going to do some examples in
a in a second so so those are those are
some things that are available and then
there's some other more mystical powers
if you get into pythons iteration
features you
you might encounter things like
generators and generator expressions
this is a little bit of an interesting
thing if you've what do they call that
noms if uses if you were to say
something like squares is equal to x
times X for X and noms just with parens
like that it doesn't actually do the
calculation it's a it treats this sort
of interesting kind of generator object
what happens there is it will feed you
values one at a time if you do a for
loop it turns out if you know what
you're doing with this you can use these
to save a huge amount of memory your
program like you can actually set up
calculations on very large data sets and
do streaming and all sorts of other
other things that's not really a we're
not going to really do a tutorial about
more on that here but if you haven't if
you if you're looking for something very
interesting that would be something to
to look at so so what we've got if
you've got these got these built-in
types no useful for different things
what I thought we would do is a little
data analysis project here this will
either end really badly or over yeah
it'll be good here involving some data
from the city of Chicago data a lot of
cities are sort of publishing data sets
these days we can download all sorts of
interesting things about potholes and
crime and you know rats other things
like that so so I so I thought for after
lunch what we could look at would be the
city of Chicago health food inspection
database um Health and Human Services so
the city actually publishes data set so
one hundred thirty thousand rows CSV
file from the health department and
we're gonna grab that and look at some
things related to food here so this yeah
hopefully everybody is well eaten after
after lunch here so I'm just gonna do
this stuff entirely with built in ties I
keep keep in mind you could you could
definitely do this kind of thing with
pandas or some other other things but I
think it's kind of useful to just see
the the built-in types and
action as well so what I'm gonna do here
is I'm gonna use Python CSV module to
grab this file as a list of dictionary
this is maybe the most inefficient way
of representing data possible in Python
but it's also super simple and memory is
infinite so yeah I find it amazing that
you can can you order up like a terabyte
of memory on Amazon these days so yeah
if needed I can I can I can go there
so so what I've done is I've read this
this food food database let's just take
a quick look at it here it's comes back
with about a hundred and thirty thousand
records this is what one of them looks
like okay so this is this is the kind of
stuff that the city publishes you get
information about the name of the
business what does address is you know
what kind of what kind of facility is it
when was it inspected you know what were
the results of the inspection you know
pass and so forth so it's some some some
information from from the city there
here's um here's another one just to see
something more interesting here so this
is a another another record here they
will actually put in their notes of them
on the inspection in the database so you
can this this is still a pass you know
it says passed with conditions but it's
a but you but you see like certain
violations listed there about you know
different different things here you know
observed black-ish colored stains or
okay okay that's not making me feel very
hungry at the moment but it's a but they
they're publishing this this this sort
of sort of data there and some of the
some of the things that you might want
to do or just start exploring just kind
of exploring that the data a little bit
so one of the things that you might
focus on might be something like you
know like what is just the result of a
health inspection like okay so you get a
health inspector showing up like what
are the possible outcomes of that that
they that they care about well that's
that's one place where you might put a
use something like asset comprehension
what I'm going to do here
is I'm gonna just go over the database I
mean it's gonna go over all the rows of
data and I'm just going to collect all
the results just give me all the results
but I'm using the fact that sets drop
all their duplicates out so this is
going to give me all the unique result
so it comes back and says okay that
those are the past the possible outcome
you know business I've found and either
fails no entry out of business pass and
so forth maybe I use that to filter the
data down like maybe I'm interested in
who failed their health inspection so I
could use something like a list
comprehension I could say well why don't
you give me all the rows for row and
food if the results are equal to fail
okay so it's iterating over that data
and we can we can look at that and say
okay well we get twenty twenty five
thousand records of Health failed health
inspection let's take a look at one of
them just so we can what we can see what
it looks like here so this is this is
what a failed inspection looks like I
mean you get the you know business name
fails again we get this list of
violations there that are you know sort
of telling us you know what what is
wrong or what happened with their their
inspection there and once once you start
down this road I mean you can start
thinking about like other kinds of
questions like like one question that
you might start asking is like what
would be the would be the worst place to
eat in Chicago these are these are
questions that you don't want to you
often don't want to know the answer to
maybe but so so so what you may be maybe
what you could do is you could do
something like I know you could make a
counter object say okay I'm gonna make a
counter out of maybe the doing business
of name for row and fail and just
tabulate that and then and then we could
take a look at that and say well okay
maybe but give me the top five so subway
Dunkin Donuts McDowell now now to be
fair now to be fair I don't I'm not here
to like dis on subway or McDonald hey
McDonald's yesterday okay
these are
the reason they have the most failures
is that they have the most locations
okay I mean there's not like one subway
in Chicago okay so there's there so
there's a lot of locations there the
other the other thing that is really
interesting about this result is just
how in the hell do you spell McDonald's
okay your your your actually say this is
common problem somebody at lunch was
asking about data munging into the
format and that's all of a sudden we've
got this problem of like well what is
the canonical spelling of McDonald's in
the database so so you're gonna you
start thinking about these problems like
I can I clean up the data or do I you
did do something with actually it's a
little bit worse than that because if
you go to if I expand that out a little
bit let's go to the top 15 you actually
find that there's like another
McDonald's down here with 20 slight with
the lowercase C so it got like
McDonald's McDonald's without the
apostrophe McDonald's with the lowercase
it's like yeah oh and you even see like
subway there's like a subway with
different capitalization and it's like
that it's you've got a clean we can do
that I'm gonna do this this is my
shatter your head a little bit I'm gonna
do a cleaning step here we're going to
do a list comprehension where I'm going
to take the row exactly what as it is
but then I'm gonna rewrite the doing
business name and I'm gonna do some
hacks on it one of the things I'm gonna
do is replace the single quote with an
empty string and then I'm going to
uppercase it
now the first part of this is actually
something you may or may not have seen
this is a Python 3/5 feature that is
going on here what is doing what what
that's doing is it's taking a dictionary
row and then I'm like merging in new
keys into it and getting a new
dictionary out kind of a exotic sort of
weird feature but it's a I'm showing you
that so you can take it home and then
like spring that on your coworkers and
so so so you can you can you can do that
let's go ahead and do our worst you know
worst thing here and see if see if we
get a different different result here
and ok so good got cleaned up a little
bit I mean we have a few more you know
Subway is McDonald's kind of went up a
little bit we're still not totally out
of the woods I have to admit like this
data cleaning stuff what about
McDonald's with a space down at the
bottom here I'm not gonna fix that in
the talk but it's like you yeah it gives
you kind of the idea though you get
these these real-world data sets I'm
gonna like now god it's like you know
they're not spelling it correctly
there's all sorts of all sorts of crazy
stuff actually on a side note one of the
most interesting talks I ever saw at the
Chicago Python user group with somebody
giving a talk about deduplicating
database data set it was like insane
like how like how do you deep duplicate
like street addresses or something where
there's like subtle spelling variations
and all sort of all sorts of stuff and I
was like that's that's crazy
blew my mind at the at the top so so
this is this you know kind of one thing
to start you can say okay well those are
bad places to bad places to e maybe a
different kind of question this is kind
of a well one of the things about this
is there's lots of different subways
lots of different McDonald's maybe you
could do a different kind of tabulation
where you actually just want to focus on
like the worst street address to go to
like you're not so much concerned about
the like the name of the restaurant but
like where's the worst look
to go to in Chicago you know to find to
find food so so what I'm doing here is a
tabulation with counters kind of based
on the street address once let's look at
that okay so so what what I'm doing here
is kind of kind of breaking things down
into you know my street address so this
like 11 601 West to 180 failed health
code violations you're like like what's
going on what's going on there Levitt
500 West Madison I guess before we go
into what that location is there are
some other there are some other more
exotic things that you can do it here's
something that will kind of kind of blow
your mind a little bit um I'm gonna make
a default dictionary of counters you're
like what is he doing here
what I'm gonna do here is I'm gonna
tabulate all of the health code failures
by year and I'm just gonna look at like
that this is worth like a clustering
kind of thing so what I'm gonna do here
is I'm going to I think it's inspection
deed I'm gonna take the inspection date
last four digits of the year and then
I'm going to use the street address and
I'm gonna add like add one to it we'll
see if that work the idea here is
something I've taken the data where I
can now go to a specific year and ask
like what were the worst street
addresses in 2015 or what were the worst
street addresses in 2014 are the worst
street addresses in 2013 okay so yeah
2016 isn't looking too good either for
this but by going this this this this
like default ticked of counter stuff
this knowing like the built-in types and
how to navigate that but I would say
this is like an example of that I have I
do a lot of this in like day to day work
where it's like I need to take some data
and cluster it or do something with it
knowing about these things and being
able to just do it super useful useful
thing all right so so we've got these
sums we've got these bad street
addresses let's let's go back to the to
the to the master list here um that one
one 601 West 2e is just like some kind
of Hell like failed failed health
inspections and I guess the question is
you know what what is that I mean why
would that be so so bad this will test
your Chicago Street knowledge but I'm
gonna let's ID it that is O'Hare Airport
okay so if you've been out at O'Hare a
lot of restaurants a lot of things that
O'Hare okay in fact let's grab all the
O'Hare all the O'Hare stuff here so
we're gonna do all the row or row in
fail this will give you useful knowledge
for leaving town probably okay so so
what we're gonna do here is okay so we
have a I'll make sure we picked up no
there's probably a spelling mistake
somewhere
it was like a hundred and eighty with
west to e but there's probably an
address with like a slightly different
spelling in there we can do it we can do
a street address to find out like asset
comprehension to find out the difference
so okay so then there was one that
identified like a specific terminal so
okay now you could never have data
that's too messy there so so we so now
I've got I've got 181 failed health
inspections from O'Hare Airport we could
ask questions about well just who are
these things that are fine what are the
businesses that are failing I'll do
another set thing so this is going to
give me a unique set of everybody who
has failed a health inspection at O'Hare
Airport and I don't know whether that's
a complete list of everything I know
here but it's uh
but you definitely get the list you know
American Airlines you know also all
sorts of all sorts of things they're
kind of kind of fun stuff there and then
you could you know what one of the
things that you could start doing with
this is I have I made people to
sufficiently disturb turns out that that
that navigating its data one of the
things one of the things that that the
data has is it has like a doing business
as name but it also has a also known as
name and turns out of it on this also
known as name they actually identify the
location and O'Haire like where this
thing is located so like this is like
terminal yeah this probably Terminal
three my gate g3 or something like that
so one of the one of the things that we
could we could do is maybe try to
identify like the worst location at
O'Hare to to eat here so yeah let's
let's let's let's try them up like it's
soon after this talk okay okay so we're
gonna do is to do a counter of just like
okay what is the also known as name for
all the rows and you know here that have
failed here and then let's do like a
most comment on comment on that these
are answers that you usually don't want
to know the question - okay so um so
you're starting to break this down it's
like okay macaroni grill
Terminal three by gay to k2 that's a
word now to be fair six versus five it's
not you know it's not like it's not like
a huge difference between the top
contenders here but you're definitely
getting different locations you know
like know Gate Gourmet I think it's the
isn't that the I'm trying to think is up
like online is that this food service on
the plane is that the on the plane there
did the different clubs for the elite
travelers are up there
United Club and so forth so a lot of a
lot of wanna kind of fun fun stuff there
10 10 minutes yeah fun fun fun things
now some other some other things with
the with the data the liberals continued
to work with this here data for for a
second here one thing that is also one
of the things that have done a lot here
is just sort of like tabulating data but
one of the things that you might try to
do is more like clustering of data to
get more information out of it this is
something where these like these default
dictionaries are actually really useful
if you want to like collect data so one
of the things that you could that you
could do let me see if I could do this
here what I'm gonna do is let's look at
the data again okay so this is what one
of the one of the records for that looks
like I'm gonna make a default dictionary
this is this default dictum list idea
where I'm gonna try to collect all of
the inspections for every single
restaurant and O'Haire separately maybe
by like their license number or
something so so what I could do is maybe
iterate over the O'Hare data and then
I'm gonna take the like the business
license number as a key and then I'm
just going to append the like the result
of that so so what's gonna happen here
is this inspections dictionary is
something where you can I can give it
like a license number like two 40 to 80
80 and then it will give me all of the
records for that that failed there okay
looks like they only had one failed at
that at that restaurant if I were to
look at the keys of this dictionary oh
it's okay they're there the license
numbers I could try different license
numbers and get like their inspection
date okay there's there's there's
there's what's there
okay that's Chile okay couple of a
couple couple of failed things you can
expand this
to do other things like if I wanted to
just get like their inspection date you
can do things like what like that I mean
I'm sort of saying okay give me the
inspection date for row and inspections
on some license date you're getting like
the dates that they failed their health
inspections there again you've got
breaking down data it's kind of
exploring it you think the built in you
know built in Thai doing kind of fun fun
stuff like that so that's a kind of kind
of an example of clustering another
thing that we might look at how much
time do I have left five five minutes or
something like that
we could give it a go okay here's here's
another question that you could ask what
is the most common way that a place at
O'Hare fails its health inspection if
you look at this violations thing like
like look at let's let's look at one of
these like by oh okay that's not a good
one there let's look at oh here what
okay so you have this this violations
text here that violations text there's
actually a some structure to that you'll
notice that the text is basically
separated by like vertical bars there's
like different sections and then it's
broken down into like numeric like code
violations it looks like there's some
numeric codes and then there's some
comments one of the things that you
might be able to do is is take that and
deep like decompose it into different
things like I might be able to take the
violations and maybe split it on like
the vertical bar like that that would
give me like the different actual like
violation parts and then I might be able
to strip out that that comments section
out of there as well just trying to
think like how how deep of a hole I want
to bury myself in here so so so so he
did that we're just gonna prototype this
a little bit okay so that this is kind
of giving me the the raw violations
maybe what I could do to clean that up
is I will I'm gonna try to slice this
thing this is this is so bad this is
really bad
am i this seen a an end quote I am
missing a net Oh comment yeah okay so
okay so we're gonna we're gonna try to
kind of strip this thing down I'm gonna
I'm gonna lose like total style points
I'm gonna strip it a white space to just
to kind of kind of normalize that there
so maybe one of the things that we could
do is we're gonna maybe want to try to
like find out like the worst like what
is the work the most common like
violation of health code it'll hair we
might be able to do this in a single
statement maybe I don't know this is
this this is gonna be a really bad idea
probably but what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna do for now okay I'm gonna do the
thing that I just did no actually no I
probably don't want to do that okay so
so actually here's what here's what I'm
gonna do um I'm gonna make a list of all
violations is gonna be row violations
I'm gonna split it on that vertical bar
I'm gonna go ahead and strip it at the
same time of white stays and then I'm
gonna do this forever everything you
know here okay so oh no I can't do that
okay okay so so this is this is gonna
give me a list of like all violations
for each each thing that's there and
then what I'm going to do is I guess
I'll make a counter of this
and I'm gonna kind of do the same thing
that I that I just did here I'm kind of
doing this the long way but that's that
that it does okay okay so
oh wait no okay be comments okay no am I
missing a brace on that I am okay
there's the fine then there's a strip
and there's like a yeah like that
thanks about yeah it should be using
notebook yeah much less than learned on
less less than Pleasant learned on that
next time okay so it's so sort of this
if this work and I'm not confident that
it did but it said well we'll find out
yeah we come in here and it you know
it's gonna coming up saying okay these
these are sort of the most common health
violations they find out a yellow hair
you know food and dime throwing food
contact a lot of stuff it floors
ceilings and so whether that took
concern to you or not I don't I don't
know but I probably almost out of time
at this point I think my but I don't
know if there's like some take away on
this talk other than like we're gonna
we're to eat at O'Hare what don't eat at
Subway ask subway no I'll stick with no
it's I think looks like a takeaway on
this stuff no IIIi feel like this sort
of thing even though it may have just
completely shattered your counters and
default Dick's all that stuff I think
but for me
this is absolutely the most useful
day-to-day thing in Python that I do do
this a lot and so if and it's also one
of the places in Python that changes all
that over time you know it's a book
author you know I'm always kind of
updating things and you know every new
version of Python it seems like there's
some new evil trick that has shown out
somewhere with the with the built-ins
and it really is kind of paid off to
look at so to look at some of that so
that that's kind of the and I do have
like us thanks slide here so just like
to thank people for you know
coming to this I hope that wasn't too
crazy but I can see if there's questions
and all right